well I think no two things going on in
the UK market first and foremost
obviously sterling has been materially
weak and continues to be against the
dollar and for the UK stock market with
so many big multinationals companies the
report in dollars you're automatically
getting those upgrades to profit
expectations so this is partly why the
UK is doing so well if you stress the
footsie in dollar terms we're not doing
so well and the second thing really is
the big consequences of both brexit and
Trump last year are that people have
voted for change they voted for an end
to their current monetary policies we've
seen post financial crisis very
negligible or negative interest rates
they voted for you know fiscal stimulus
Trump coming in to get a try and target
higher levels of growth so the bond
market is on the slide so after this
great 35 year bond bull market it's
finally beginning to sell off and the
markets are going well faster growth
that could be good news we could have a
little bit of Goldilocks where inflation
doesn't really pick up for a while and
yet the equities benefit from stronger
growth so it's a so-called reflation
trade rather than outright inflation I
mean we can look at the footsie here
I mean it's some since the referendum
stunning recovery as you say though in
dollar terms that picture would be
completely flat wouldn't it it would yes
sadly when you go abroad you know we are
poorer as a nation there's also of the
weakness of sterling but yes it's very
good news for many of our big
multinational companies I mean you
mentioned sterling dollar we can have a
look at that one today I mean sterling
today was flirting with new two-month
lows against the dollar I mean
presumably that's why the footsies up
again there's there's an automatic rally
in the footsie every time Sterling goes
like that's it's absolutely correct and
I suspect that sadly is Sterling is
going to continue to be the safety valve
for the UK economy because of our twin
deficits you know it's really the only
thing that can help the economy if it is
weaker through the course of this year
but what about company earnings Richard
I mean share price is there a function
of earnings expectations the footsies
trading at relatively high historic
ratings are those earnings going to come
through well I think for these big
dollar sensitive stocks
are getting the upgrades to earnings
expectations purely on currency basis so
I think you're pretty safe there
clearly as we've just heard the issue
for some of the more domestic names you
know UK retailers next prime case in
point and you know this is where people
are still concerned you haven't seen the
last downgrade barked commissural e
that's where the shares have already
de-rated very very strongly so it could
be that there's some moment during the
course of this year when you've got a
start you know holding your nose and
plunging into buying some of these more
domestic names big big cool for
investors like you then what about the
u.s. a lot of expectations you I mean
you mentioned it yourself Trump equals
growth is that necessarily going to
happen I think this could be a year well
as a lot of traveling and arriving I
think you're the euphoria about the
first hundred days and so on markets I
think will continue to rally through
that and then they'll be perhaps a
little bit of well actually is it coming
through or is the strength of the dollar
actually taking the shine off US
corporate profits the flip side of what
we're seeing here and we'll the D rating
of equities if bond yields keep rising
stars have become a feature it wouldn't
surprise me if at some stage next year
this year you had a surprisingly
positive wage inflation number coming
out of the US because it's running at 3%
already and if he's going to pour more
fuel onto a pretty full employment
situation anyway so lots of things where
I think you know markets could run
through to Easter but then it could be a
lot stickier in their kind of subsequent
months very very brief word on the
eurozone Richard is there gonna be any
car crashes there this year no I think
that in contrast to many people the
elections throughout Europe this year
will produce absolutely nothing in terms
of dramatic change this is not the year
that the euro is going to have any major
existential crisis I think the German
economy you know the consumer could
actually surprise on the positive side
this year